it's been nearly 18 months we've been
keeping track and Hillary Clinton's
Blaine train is not even close to
running out of fuel it's getting
concerning well speaking on Tuesday
night at the wing which is a women-only
Club in New York which because it's
women only it's not sexist Clinton began
blaming everybody to the NRA to misogyny
itself for her defeat in the 2016
election here's part of it you know I've
taken on the NRA for years and they've
spent more money against me than they've
ever spent against anybody and now we
know the Russians paid for some of it
you know paid for actors or Russian
agents personnel you know to dress up in
those very attractive jail outfits and
go around in a mock Jail people could
get a lock her up we know who's on MSNBC
his website at midnight every night it's
not a political speech that was more
like group therapy and honestly the easy
thing would be to make fun of Hillary
Clinton who she's so wrong but it's past
that this is sad well anyone help her
she's crying out for where are her
friends her husband the DNC it's like
watching someone you know fall apart
it's poignant and tragic and someone
ought to help Tammy Bruce is a radio
host and she joins us to me Tammy I'm
only half joking I do whatever else this
is this is not empowering for women as
the father of three daughters I can say
that conclusively right and look I mean
there is a point where you never think
you'd say this but you do begin to feel
sorry for her yeah and as a political
person look a part of what her complaint
was at that event was that Fox News is
trying to quote impeach her in other
words that that there's coverage of her
on this network there's actually
interestingly of course the complaints
have come from other Democrats across
the network
people who actually work for her
campaign but but she's in a unique
opportunity here in a unique position
where since she is getting coverage and
she's clearly as searching for relevance
she could talk about policy yes she
could use this so that we would actually
be discussing an argument that she could
be having such a smart businessman also
you know frankly maybe then she would be
on the tucker carlson show and you could
have this conversation because actually
she knows a lot and she's not stupid and
she's been around a long time and
Schenley her claim to fame always was
I've read the policies only I and
there's some truth in that actually and
she could be doing that but she's not in
the White House she's obviously been in
the Senate she's been the Secretary of
State and yet this is devolved into this
a group therapy dynamic where she's
going over the same complaints that
people if they're in that that group
maybe they've read her book they know
what her complaints are but she's also
then inserting news of the day like now
suddenly it's it's the Cambridge
analytic and it's the NRA because that's
the news that's happening now at this
point it's almost as though she's on an
episode of intervention where people
really should try to get her into the
van to get her to the plane to get her
to the place where she can find some
peace because it does get to a point
where that's a real it's it's almost an
abdication of a responsibility she could
have to all of her fans and supporters
to really deal seriously with the issues
because they too want solutions and she
still with this great attention
internationally is not using the
platform she has to present those
solutions and it is it's sad and I think
that there could be even though I would
disagree with her solutions we at least
then could move forward on these issues
and try to make a difference so that's
exactly right
we could add to the sum total of the
conversation which is important even if
you disagree I'm we try to do it every
night by the way that's her speaking
live we actually don't have a huge
desire to cover everything Hillary
Clinton despite her acclaim but I think
it's interesting in times make one other
point yeah the irony which people are
not kind of perceiving is that her party
has moved very far from where she was
she we will long for a time when Hillary
Clinton was the most radical person in
the Democratic Party and she's way too
moderate for Democrats by and large
right now she is
and that actually is an interesting
position she could be in in arguing the
things that she and her husband used to
represent which was balanced budgets and
getting people off of welfare and into
work and all of that I mean if she
wanted to be serious that's what she
could be doing arguments about how to
improve the quality of women's lives you
know you could argue that she says
nobody else has been attacked like her
and nobody else was told to go away like
she's been told to go away but Al Gore
and John McCain and and and John Kerry
actually continued to talk about policy
you know we can disagree with what they
stood for but as as a woman I think that
there are so many other opportunities
with the platform she has her own party
is saying you know enough is enough at
this point yeah if one of my kids acted
like that I'd be very upset really
quickly so Christian privileges is a new
category seminar at George Washington
University here in Washington we'll
examine how Christians get quote
unmerited perks and have built-in
advantages over everybody else in
America you actually look at the numbers
Christians are not anyway are actually
not thriving in this country this is all
measured but what do you make of this to
say this out loud seems like a change
well look I'm I don't identify as a
Christian I believe in God but I believe
that Jesus is the guy I think it's a
very serious thing to identify as a
Christian and so I'm taking it seriously
and slowly but as looking from the
outside what I see as a political
commentator and an analyst is Christians
maybe have a privilege of being
persecuted and attacked and and martyred
around the world I mean it is a
remarkable attack dynamic even here at
home Facebook had to apologize for
refusing to Catholic universities add
that feature Jesus on the cross because
it was too violent
remember the chick-fil-a controversy the
so-called controversy because of its
owner being a Christian man even the
attacks that Billy Graham at his death
went under because of its Christian
faith so there's no privilege there
except I think to be model is it Tim
it's great to see you thank you